[Música]
[Aplausos]
durante años durante los últimos años yo
no veía fotos de mí no me gustaba no me
sentía cómoda y evitaba que me las
tomaran
cuando veía fotos recientes mías veía
una persona que no reflejaba la persona
que yo sentía hacer por dentro mi
historia no es muy diferente a la de
muchas mujeres de mi edad me casé con el
amor de mi vida tuve dos hijos
maravillosos estudie lo que quise y
trabaje y bueno y trabaje lo que quise y
conseguí un trabajo maravilloso y muy
noble
realmente mi vida ha tenido cosas mucho
más buenas que malas entonces no sé por
qué pero logré subir bastante de peso
si esa soy yo hace unos años en un viaje
familiar acapulco cuando me veo ahí allí
pues no me gustó verme no me gustó verme
como la cara como se me vio a las
expresiones esa persona estaba cansada
estaba agobiada y tenía muchos problemas
en su espalda
decidí hacer un análisis de mi vida al
final siempre dicen que los 40 es un
buen momento para hacer una pausa y
analizar las decisiones que has tomado y
que te han llevado a la situación que en
la que me encontraba
entonces un evento récord de un evento
hace 10 años cuando mis hijos estaban
pequeños y ya podían entrar al kinder
cuando se me dio la oportunidad de
regresar a trabajar yo estaba muy
contenta porque realmente siempre me ha
gustado hacer muchas cosas y dije pues
hay que tener el paquete completo no
familia niños trabajo está padrísimo sin
embargo a los pocos meses se me dio un
encargo muy muy complicado
algo realmente que fue catastrófico en
mi salud y fue implementar el transporte
obligatorio en el lugar donde trabajo en
una escuela
fue un proyecto muy muy difícil en donde
ahora la distancia lo analizó y veo que
me comí todos los problemas que se
originaron cargues sobre mi espalda
responsabilidades que se originaron por
las decisiones de terceras personas y al
final pienso que ese fue el momento en
el que inició este patrón de comerme los
problemas
y decidí parar decidí identificarlos y
decidí que no podía seguir
no podía seguir cargando problemas que
se originan en otro en otra parte fuera
de mí
estos dos garrafones cuando yo intento
cargarlos el otro día me pidieron que
moviera bonos
realmente no los cargué y dije wow bueno
esto es el equivalente a lo que yo
estuve cargando durante 8 años
aproximadamente
y decidí que no que no podía seguir así
que mi cuerpo no estaba hecho para
cargar este peso y tampoco estaba hecho
para cargar problemas y para comer menos
ya tenía yo el por qué pero ahora tenía
que saber el cómo por qué dietas todas
sirven si las haces el problema es que
yo no quería volver a hacer una dieta y
volver a dejarla y volver a subir de
peso quería llegar a algo que funcionara
y me dediqué a estudiar en las noches me
dediqué a leer muchísimo sobre la
ciencia detrás del alimento de cómo se
procesa y finalmente
encontré es no es nada nuevo pero
encontré que el azúcar no se está
realmente haciendo muchísimo daño no
suele la azúcar obvia de dulces y
chocolate sino también la que
aparentemente sana en forma de harinas y
granos y frutas decidí eliminarlas un
tiempo de mi vida y ese fue el resultado
hoy en día logré recuperar mi peso y
logré recuperar mi salud y sobre todo mi
alegría por la vida
ahora veo hacia adelante y veo que tengo
muchísimos años todavía para hacer
nuevos proyectos para enseñar a mis
hijos que no te debes de comer los
problemas que debes e identificarlos
debes de analizarlos y debes de
colocarlos en un lugar donde los puedas
ver irlos atacando poco a poco
cuando uno encuentra las razones por las
que tiene un sobrepeso y encuentra el
como correctamente quitártelo encima se
hace una sinergia increíble
ya no me tomo los problemas de otras
personas ni los míos los asumo con
responsabilidad pero no me los como los
voy atacando un poco a poco'
ya no como azúcar hoy me estoy
certificando como head coach porque veo
que es una etapa que se abre ante mí
como una opción muy emocionante de
ayudar a más personas y sobre todo
también de ayudarme a mí
y al final lo que yo quiero sobre todo
decirle a mis hijos es que sus problemas
los manejen bien
que no se los convite
y eso es todo gracias
[Aplausos]